the new look for British flag vessels in
the Strait of Hormuz here
HMS Montrose was sandwiched in between
two merchant vessels yesterday it's the
first known transit of UK flag ships
through the Straits since this happened
Iranian special forces captured the
Senate in pyro tanker last Friday
afterwards
Britain warned other vessels to steer
clear of this vital waterway now they're
being advised to steer into it but with
Royal Navy protection if you were a
Seafarer on board a vessel going through
the Straits of Hormuz now and you had no
escorts at all you might feel extremely
worried particularly if you're on a
British flag on the other hand if
there's a nice large British warship
sailing next door to you I would guess
you'd feel extremely extremely better
place so of course yes it will restore
confidence very very welcome britain's
not the only nation with nice big
warships the USS boxer is one of a
number of American vessels sent to the
Gulf amid tensions with Iran
Washington's building a coalition of
navies to protect International shipping
London and European allies had been
reluctant to join as they opposed US
policy on Iran there's even been talk of
a separate European LED force though
many are unconvinced the idea that we
should do this in concert only with the
strategic powerhouse that the European
Union is brackets not closed brackets
rather than with our US allies that has
serious forces in the Gulf is quite
frankly
impractical to the point of lunacy the
extra protection for ships came too late
for these men
the crew of the Senate in Pierrot are
still hostages of Iran it once London to
release a tanker Britain help seas off
the coast of Gibraltar no sign of that
route being resolved but these men have
finally been allowed to speak to their
families no respite for HMS Montrose yet
either still on alert in case of another
Iranian assault
Deborah Haynes Sky News the United Arab
Emirates